I want to pull up one of your tweets to
talk about the demoralization and the
normalization of extremist rhetoric
that's Shifting the the narratives and
the opinions in this country so you have
you have actually there are two tweets
from you the first you said step one
feds did not Infiltrate The Very Maga
groups they blame for one six step two
yeah they did but it's not a big deal
step three it's a good thing actually in
step four people freaking out about it
are the real problem right you then
quoted that and said the Tucker NSA
story went from step one to step four in
less than 24 hours now I don't want to
get completely into those stories we
will in a second I want to bring this
back to uh this story
black lives matter Utah chapter declares
American flag a symbol of hatred and the
reason I brought up your tweets is that
first we saw it was it was Mara gay on
MSNBC saying that she was Disturbed
seeing these these American flags in the
back of these trucks what did everyone
say she didn't mean she was disturbed by
the American flag she was talking about
the people who were flying it and that
they were flying at what they were
saying about the country and they had
all of this like inference that wasn't
there all this context they make up
we're moving this direction the first
step is no she didn't
now they're saying well so what if they
did now we're actually hearing black
lives matter Utah put out a Facebook
post saying those who fly the American
flag are racists so where are we at the
embassies are flying black lives matter
Flags right you're seeing certain
institutions flying Pride Flags equal to
or even above or black lives matter
Flags equal to or above and we're moving
in this direction in Evanston Illinois
they canceled the Fourth of July parade
over covid but then had pride and
Juneteenth celebrations right as if
covet was totally irrelevant so in in
the previous segment you were talking
about color revolutions I'm looking at
that formula you give step one and I'll
you know put it in the context of the
American flag no they're not saying they
don't like the American flag no they're
not criticizing the American flag step
two okay well they did but who cares
it's just black lives matter Utah it's
not even a big organization
soon we're gonna get to the point where
they're like actually they're making a
good point aren't they we'll see it on
MSNBC there'll be some controversy
around it and they'll say but they make
a good point I mean that flag was
created by these racists and then step
four they're gonna be like how could
these people defend racism that's where
we'll end up no absolutely and it's a
sign it's actually I take this as a
point of you know you have to give
credit to uh
the ruling ideology they're always on
the offensive right they're always on
the offensive and this this succession
of steps simply illustrates that said
they get what they want from the first
step and they move on they're incredibly
flexible and they end up getting what
they want even when they're proven wrong
because the damage is already done and
we just have to kind of understand that
uh recognize that and if you know to the
extent possible reverse reverse engineer
it and you know understanding what power
is how how it's wielded where it's where
it comes from what its infrastructure is
that's something that needs to be just
uh
on on everyone's Minds who's interested
in Playing for Keeps which is a very
rare quality these days the past
pessimism in me comes from the fact that
uh people on the right have no
organizational power I mean like you
mentioned they control no major
institutions right it's all the left
right now there there is a a potential
um
light at the end of that tunnel in that
you don't want to be a frog boiling in a
pot but what happens if you throw
boiling water at a frog that Frog's
gonna be like yo they just threw boiling
water at me it's gonna jump out of the
way because the right has been so weak
in this there is the potential that this
shocks regular people like throwing
boiling water at a frog case in point
what Steve Bannon was saying that these
mothers are now all of a sudden getting
smacked in the face by this extremism
from these schools this this critical
race applied principles in schools where
you know if you teach the kid little
bits over the course of 10 years there's
nothing a parent could do to fight back
against that the kid has been
indoctrinated but they're coming in in
in in half a year in one year and
telling the kids your parents are liars
they're evil they're oppressors and so
now the mom says what'd you learn in
school and the kid goes you're evil and
they go what or with the zoom classes we
have that story about the um the lady
who gets fired for you know explaining
the kids how to take care of business on
their own if you know what I mean
pleasuring themselves something the kids
probably should not be exposed to
actually I'm going to say this
six-year-olds should not be exposed to
that you don't have an argument about
high schoolers that was another part of
the of the debate well YouTube censor
you for saying that no no I don't know I
mean but we we have to be very very
careful so what people need to
understand about all the censorship
stuff is
do we just see this ground and this
ability to communicate just saying the
you know just going full steam ahead or
do we try and you know use the networks
of the best of our abilities to stay in
the fight I've been thinking a lot it
depends so along with this metaphor I'm
thinking the culture War if it's two
armies lined up facing each other in
battle if you if you become demoralized
in black pill you're basically routing
from the battle you're giving up you're
turning and you're running in the middle
of combat and you're leaving your allies
open to being flanked by the people that
you should have been engaged with on the
other side now they're going to go and
flank your your friends they're gonna
get destroyed you're going to lose the
battle alternately there are times when
you're realizing your your army is
losing the battle and you need an
organized Retreat that's different than
a route that's different than a black
pill in cases like the education system
I think in organized Retreat away from
that system could be valuable there have
been so many prominent
anti-establishment YouTubers who in the
past several years just dropped to their
knees and said there are five lights
that it is particularly demoralizing to
see because it is easier I mean look man
you want to be an edgy YouTube channel
you want to get all those followers yeah
eight years ago now you've got the
establishment machine saying be
assimilated resistance is futile and a
bunch of these big channels went you
know what it's just easier just easier
well I mean the the internet that I
don't need to tell you the internet that
existed six years ago is not the
internet we have today it's totally
different phenomenon so
um yeah and that's I think a major shift
in how we need to kind of strategize
about how to how to get the message out
how to wield power how to organize is
that there was this brief period where
we had more or less uncensored internet
and that proved to be simply too
effective and so really you know the I
think one of the most important videos
everyone should watch all in bakari I
think it was on it was on this this uh
this show and he he released a video of
the entire Google c-suite yeah the day
after the election the entire c-suite
just literally crying and saying we will
never let this happen again and uh I
would like to talk about big Tech
because I do have some some kind of
different different takes on that I
think might be interesting uh
interesting to your audience about what
it actually is so this is uh I guess
just I'm not trying to be overly
pessimistic we try to keep a little bit
of a balance because we've been very
pessimistic in the past but
hearing that Google
higher ups you know they're crying
saying don't worry right I don't believe
any of these people when they're like oh
we're being fair no they're not we we
are absolutely in the resistance and I
wonder I've said on this show before
that this show is basically basically a
pressure release valve for for the
establishment like I mentioned with
frogs boiling in a pot if they nuke
Stephen Crowder and eliminate him off of
YouTube completely you're gonna get
millions of really angry people I mean
he's getting what like 50 million views
per month that's millions of people who
are going to be like
very angry that they're being silenced
or not heard or that they're you know
they can't express themselves and that
could be like throwing boiling water at
a frog right so they keep channels like
his on the ropes they keep channels like
mine around so that the frogs are
boiling people still listen to this they
still feel like there is some semblance
of a chance when in reality every major
institution is already under control and
if they wanted to they could just snap
their fingers and wipe us off the
internet
right and man that's that's the two
sides of the coin there's the black pill
and there's there's the cope and uh so
are you are you saying there's the black
pill there's the cope but there's that
very thin edge of the coin of the hope
uh and and I think that's that's the the
line that we need to skate on but you
have to be very creative and you have to
come you have to think you know
realistically about things you have to
understand that now the the chess board
is
International and I think one thing we
need to understand is the more
consolidation ideologically that exists
within the domestic sphere
um the more we lose moral authority to
exert our power geopolitically and the
stage is is an international one so the
more
the United States or I call this new
version of the United States I've coined
this term the globalist American Empire
uh which has you know I think a
convenient acronym and uh this is
basically
the globalist American Empire
the more it consolidates ideologically
in a domestic sense the more it loses
its Prestige and its standing
geopolitically and this is what we were
talking about off air about this concept
of taboo Arbitrage is that you know I
this is kind of why I take a more I hate
to use the word nuanced approach to
China but I think it's a good thing that
there's a genuinely independent sphere
of power
that is separate from that of the
globalist American Empire that has is
certainly authoritarian but we're
authoritarian they're a different type
of authoritarian there are things you
cannot say in China is not a free speech
state but they censor different things
and I think as long as there's a place
in the world where you can say the
things that I you know won't say because
you two will get mad
um as long as there's a place that you
could say that
perhaps in China as long as there's a
place here where you can criticize she
that's a good thing those different
taboos can be arbitraged out and I think
this general you know we have to get
very creative I've caused a lot of
controversy on another show you
mentioned Jack Murphy actually was on
his show for saying look
all this talk about you know big Tech
and everything people need to understand
they're focusing so much on big Tech
being private companies in the ultimate
sense they're not private companies
they're big Tech apparatus is an
extension of Our National Security State
in the ultimate sense that's just the
reality yeah and and so at the end of
the day they're not private companies
and in the sense that actually matters
and you see in China you know they don't
they don't allow Google they don't they
don't allow these other things and
frankly that's that's to their credit
that's why they're still an independent
society and so I suggested what if the
Chinese were to set up a server Farm on
their territory a bunch of servers and
say we are this is going to be free
speech infrastructure for Americans who
want to CR who want to talk about things
relevant to their own countries okay we
we Grant you we're not going to let you
talk about President XI we're not going
to let you talk about the uyghurs but
we're going to let you talk about all
the things that are actually relevant to
your country to your leadership to your
corrupt and illegitimate ruling class
that your big Tech infrastructure won't
allow I think that would be it that
would be an absolute winning chess move
it would be good for the people in the
United States who are disenfranchised or
targeted by their own government and
frankly it would also be a good move for
China I think it would be a win-win tick
tock
well that's actually very interesting
that's a very interesting case because
we know like this was Tick Tock was one
of the basically the only big tech
companies that the Trump Administration
went after now I'm not you know
necessarily a fan of tick tock you know
I don't use it
um my General ad you know disposition
toward it is negative but Tick Tock
compared to
Google Facebook all these others Tick
Tock is far less of a threat in terms of
censoring our free speech and in fact in
some ways there are competitors and so
to go after tick tock first rather than
Google I think is completely ineffectual
it was the wrong move and actually
serves the interests of Facebook and
Google insofar as Tick Tock is their
competitor and as far as censorship goes
Tick Tock is far less censorious than
than Google or Facebook and the
censorship that actually does occur on
Tick Tock is not coming from the Chinese
it's coming from their American people
working in their troughs and safety uh
uh uh teams who are censoring not due to
Chinese sensitivities but due to the
same old you know crap in in America is
a telegram was is that is that Russian
or uh telegram is uh Russian it's it's
created I Believe by a Russian national
called Pavel durov but it has a
complicated relationship ship with the
Russian government it's not it and so
durov is a Russian national I believe
but he's not living in Russia and so
it's not as though he's simply kowtowing
doing what Russia wants although he does
hand over data but you know all tech
companies basically all the major ones
hand over data so that's not to single
him out the challenge with
um
you know if China were to set up the
server Farm allowing people to say
whatever they want right you'll still
get the U.S intelligence apparatus using
sock puppet accounts to manipulate
people that's basically where one one
person will operate 50 accounts to make
to simulate public opinion oh absolutely
no and this is why I think that's such
an interesting exercise I say it not
half jokingly there is a serious but I
think it's just such an interesting
exercise because it's outside of the
scope of what most people strategize and
talk about when they think of the Free
Speech problem and it really goes to
show like what you're saying you're
you're your response to that it's in
spirit extremely accurate and it
underscores what I was saying is that
big Tech is an extension of Our National
Security State and people need to
understand that the bottleneck to free
speech infrastructure is not that oh um
Mark Zuckerberg just just isn't uh you
know just isn't
um
liberal enough in terms of free speech
or you know these individual people
aren't aren't open enough to free speech
they have to understand that if any
robust Free Speech infrastructure were
to be created in the United States at
scale
it would be targeted as a national
security threat I that's what happened
with Tick Tock and I think and they use
the excuse that's collecting data from
American citizens which is empowering
China right if China were server Farms
that say whatever you want to say
they're going to collect all the data
the data thing is ridiculous frankly I
would is it really such a big difference
like oh you know Google has all of my
data but heaven forbid the chi-coms have
my data as though Google is is you know
so much so much better or you know I say
I would rather have the Chinese
government have all of my information
than any American journalist and so
people at least people yeah do people
just just don't have the the you know
the proper perspective on these things
and and this is why it's like I I
understand in a geopolitical sense China
is a threat but ultimately the the
signaling power of being a China Hawk
has changed dramatically
a while ago a couple of years ago to say
that China is the number one threat the
signaling value of that position is to
say come on guys do we really need war
with Iran China is the bigger so it
really had the effect of signaling that
you weren't one of these nuts that was
obsessed with war with Iran or an even
bigger nut who wanted war with Russia to
say China is the big problem basically
it has a first order meaning it has a
sec or second order signaling meaning
saying I'm not one of those Russian nuts
I'm not one of those Iran nuts but now I
think it's it's it's taken on a very
different type of significance and you
see that in the fact that all of this
these establishment
um just just establishment filth people
like Nikki Haley these neocon nut jobs
they're just China Hawks like every
everyone else Pompeo even people
underestimate the extent to which the
Biden Administration generally is China
Hawk and so
um the signaling power has really
changed and now I think a lot of the
China Hawk stuff is simply a distraction
simply a distraction from the fact that
the real enemies of the American people
are not any foreign country like China
the real enemies of American people are
people who control America thanks for
checking out this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time